it's always an inbound Saturday we like
you know there's always more Amendment
than women but uh you know the man would
normally say oh you women you you need
to defend yourself you know with all the
things out there today you need to
defend yourself
and when I was at school and that was a
long time ago they didn't used to pick
on me the bullies
because I'm big
hands she'd said they didn't pick on
them but when they did but if anybody
did pick on me I used to learn how to
fire because I was big so I could
normally win
but what they didn't know is in the
outside world I was as frightened as
anybody had been attacked you know
because I didn't know if I could defend
myself you know I'm good in a one-to-one
fight I didn't know how good I was at
actually being out there how many would
attack me so so you don't have to be a
any gender to be bothered about
if you could handle yourself or not
um so I down I key though because I
wanted somebody's business car business
and he said come down come to the
12-week beginner's course of Aikido and
I'll give you my business for a year
and I needed it because I just started
business so I got into a really strange
way but I'm trying to tell you that my
mind was bothered about no matter how
big I am going out there or going into
town I was still welded about being
picked on
so I think self-defense is an amazing
thing but you've got to find the right
one for you
emotions let's go this is the second one
don't worry if you get lost in all of
this and as you said that young lady is
that the best you've got
laughs
so
a big person will always be difficult
but there's a place where if I concrete
this this back Lake here you see this
one I can creep that there behind him
and get sort of under him like a tree
then slowly the tree before
so you've got to work on angles and this
is where the preciseness comes into play
if I put what I call Coke here
cool
I just hit this rock so I have to put
relaxation for what he can't see is coat
you this as we call it coaching it's in
my body but it's
so it's a determination that's settled
if I try to put hope you're in all
things
then I'm gonna match
a big person or a bigger person
there's no other width but if I'm subtle
completely different that's why I'm
talking about centimeters you don't need
to worry about that today okay let's try
this